supongamos que en un país solo pueden
fabricar uno de dos bienes o alguna
combinación de ellos pueden producir
tenedores o pueden producir cucharas
este es el eje de la cantidad de
tenedores y este es el eje de la
cantidad de cucharas ahora imaginemos
que dedican toda su energía a producir
esta cantidad de tenedores y no producen
cucharas pero después deciden producir
unas pocas cucharas por lo que van a
producir una cantidad un poco menor de
tenedores y mientras más cucharas
producen menos tenedores pueden producir
hasta llegar al punto en donde solo
producen cucharas y no produce ningún
tenedor en otros vídeos hemos visto que
esta es la curva de posibilidades de
producción para este país que imaginamos
aunque los países reales son más
complejos pues producen mucho más que la
combinación de dos cosas pero este es un
buen modelo para comprender lo que los
países son capaces de hacer una forma de
comprender esta curva de posibilidades
de producción es que ésta nos muestra lo
que un país puede producir de la manera
más eficiente si usa con eficiencia
todos sus recursos entonces producirá
una combinación de cucharas y tenedores
se localiza en la curva de posibilidades
de producción este punto x es una
combinación de esta cantidad de cucharas
y esta cantidad de tenedores lo
importante de esta combinación es que es
una producción eficiente para este país
ahora tenemos este punto que llamamos y
que pasaría en este país si entrara en
recesión y por cualquier razón no pueden
usar sus recursos eficientemente
recuerden que cuando hablamos de
recursos nos referimos a la tierra las
fábricas los materiales que tiene y
quizá incluso la mano de obra en esta
situación digamos que antes operaba con
eficiencia en este punto pero cuando
ocurre la recesión la producción llega a
este punto que llamamos z que es un uso
ineficiente de sus recursos y que se
encuentra debajo de la curva de
posibilidades de producción esto es un
punto ineficiente de producción una
pregunta que podrían hacerse es qué pasa
con los puntos que están más allá de la
curva de posibilidades de producción
como en este punto que llamamos a bueno
a menos que tengamos más insumos es
decir más tierra más capital o trabajo
sí no
aumentamos los recursos aquí este será
un punto inalcanzable para este país
pero digamos que quieren alcanzar este
punto como puede ocurrir pues vamos a
requerir de inversión que aumente la
tierra o el trabajo
pensemos en este escenario dibujemos el
eje de los tenedores que este país
produce en un año y el eje de las
cucharas dibujemos la curva original de
posibilidades de producción otra forma
de pensar en esto es mostrar a lo que se
está renunciando al producir tenedores y
cucharas podemos pensar en el costo de
oportunidad de producir una cuchara en
términos de tenedores a cuántos
tenedores tenemos que renunciar porque
recuerden que aquí actúa la escasez no
tenemos una cantidad infinita de metal
para producir cosas o una cantidad
infinita de trabajo o una cantidad
infinita de fábricas pero digamos que en
este país pudieron construir más
fábricas o disponen de más tierra o
quizás más personas emigraron a este
país por lo que en esta situación habrá
crecimiento y la curva de posibilidades
de producción se desplazará hacia afuera
aquí vemos una curva de posibilidades de
producción que muestra lo que ocurre
y crecimiento qué cosa se impulsa en el
crecimiento un incremento en la cantidad
de tierra y cuando hablamos de tierra
nos referimos a un incremento en los
recursos naturales o un incremento en la
cantidad de capital que se tiene el
capital puede referirse a las fábricas o
maquinarias o también podemos tener a
más personas que nos ayudan a producir
los tenedores y cucharas también podemos
tener una mejor tecnología para producir
estos cubiertos e incluso puede haber
personas con espíritu empresarial que
encuentren mejores formas de combinar
estos recursos para producir más
tenedores y cucharas ahora imaginemos el
escenario opuesto donde este país está
en guerra con otro país es bombardeado y
varias fábricas son destruidas qué va a
pasar en esta situación esta es la curva
de posibilidades de producción antes de
la guerra pero ahora debido a esta
guerra nuestro país pierde tierra o
queda con varias fábricas u otro tipo de
capital destruido quizás varias personas
huyen de este país por lo que hay menos
trabajo y quizá por alguna razón no
pueden tener o usar tecnología en este
escenario la curva de posibilidades
se contrae y la contracción podemos
ilustrar la como un cambio hacia adentro
en la curva de posibilidades de
producción en resumen la curva de
posibilidades de producción es lo que
dice su nombre muestra las combinaciones
posibles de bienes que un país puede
producir y cualquier punto en esta curva
indica que esta nación hace un uso
eficiente de sus recursos si nos
encontramos por debajo de esta curva
indica que hay un uso ineficiente de los
recursos y si nos encontramos por afuera
o por arriba de esta curva indica una
situación en la que si no cambiamos los
insumos esta será una situación
inalcanzable la única forma en la que
podemos alcanzar los puntos más allá de
la curva es desplazando la misma curva
al tener más recursos más tierra más
capital más trabajo o más tecnología
como vimos en este escenario de en medio
nos vemos en otro vídeo